without the Black Panther, wakanda will fall
vibranium, he's covered in it
now is our time
to strike
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
Marvel dropped the New Black Panther wakanda
forever trailer so we'll break it down there's
a whole bunch of new footage if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we only have a little while
before it comes out once we get a little bit
closer also do a movie ticket giveaway but
the big thing in this trailer just giving
you way more footage with the characters especially
the New Black Panther and they pretty much
confirmed that it is sure you like you see
the weapons on our hands they're the exact
same type of weapons that she used during
the first Black Panther movie when we started
seeing those in the trailers for the first
Black Panther movie I just called her shirty
Panther hands because they're basically Panther
hands with Advanced Sonic technology the big
advantage that those gave her in her fight
with killmonger even though she wasn't that
great of a warrior at the time like he's remembered
she's about the same age as Peter Parker in
the MCU so she's actually pretty young even
though she could do a lot of things with those
they were specifically useful for fighting
against killmonger in the vibranium nanites
that were used to form his golden Jaguar black
panther suit that's also how Ulysses claw
was able to fight black panther when he was
coming after him like it was a form of Sonic
technology that interrupted the signal between
the vibranium nanites which is why it seemed
like their suits disintegrated when they were
hit by the guns obviously this being a sequel
being many years later even if you think about
the five-year time Jump being even more years
you have to remember sure he just iterates
with their technology the same way that Spider-Man
the same way that Iron Man all the other Tech
based characters in the MCU would normally
do so even though it's the technology from
the first film it's probably gotten way more
advanced since the events of the first film
but this is basically what her full suit looks
like and now that you actually get like a
full top to bottom view of her in broad daylight
you can see she's way more petite looking
than say like t'challa was the figure that
he cast when he was walking around in his
suit I've already talked about the golden
highlights all over her suit how they're kind
of influenced a little bit by killmonger's
Golden Jaguar suit and how killmonger figures
into the film like killmonger is coming back
not the way the people think that he's coming
back I talked about that in my previous Black
Panther video like oh yeah he's definitely
coming but it's a bit more of like a force
ghost Twist on killmonger with the ancestral
plane because they're not going to do like
a carry Fisher's situation with the rise of
Skywalker like they're not going to rejigger
a bunch of like old footage to bring him back
in the movie in present day I believe he's
supposed to have been dead for about a year
when the events of the movie pick up in the
present day there might be some flashbacks
during the film like I think the idea is that
we see namor's birth obviously that's a huge
flashback but the current events of the movie
I believe are meant to pick up in relatively
close to real time with the other Marvel movies
that have come out so far but because this
is like the last movie in Marvel phase four
I think they also want it to be a little bit
later in the timeline than say like Thor love
and thunder or maybe pretty close to the same
time the Thor 11 Thunder is happening fun
fact too we saw a boss the panther goddess
during Thor love and thunder that's the god
the Black Panther and all of his people worship
now like not everybody in wakanda not all
the tribes worship the panther goddess some
of them like the Jabari tribe mbaku's people
worship the ape God but I don't know whether
or not this movie is going to reference boss
the way they used her during Thor love and
thunder was more in a comedic way and they
didn't really give her any speaking lies there
might be some deleted scenes or some more
extra scenes that were involving her she was
really just there for that Zeus God had seen
where all the gods were just joking about
all the funds that they were going to have
like all the crazy stuff that they were doing
but when it comes to shuri taking the mantle
of black panther they did say the question
of who the next Black Panther winds up being
is a big part of the movie and for a lot of
the early part of the film The whole idea
is that they're arguing about who has the
right to or who should take up the mantle
of the Black Panther because like in the trailer
there's that footage where you have namor
talking to ramonda saying that wakanda has
no black panther anymore wakanda has no protector
is vulnerable which I think he's so quick
to invade wakanda and flood it I know there's
a couple questions about that too like why
is there all this water in wakanda where did
it come from isn't it supposed to be landlocked
clearly raimonda is on the coast talking to
namor here on the beach but I think the idea
is that the water that they flood will conda
with is coming one from rivers that run into
wakanda but there's also like a giant lake
near wakanda as well so it could be coming
for that too but because typically in big
movies like this there's like a big third
act twist where like you have some big hero
rally moment I'm assuming the big third act
twist will be shuri debuting as the New Black
Panther sort of at the first two halves of
the film there's still this big question about
who's going to take the mantle also there's
all that footage in the trailer with Ramada
saying that her entire family is dead which
would mean that she probably thinks that shuri
is dead at some point that might have something
to do with namor's invasion of wakanda like
they might believe that something happened
to shuri during that and because shuri is
becoming the next Black Panther there's a
lot of questions about how they're going to
handle the actual powers of the Black Panther
because previously the heart-shaped herb was
a really big part of that it was basically
like their version of the super soldier Sierra
that they would give to each Black Panther
and I believe when the movie picks up the
naturally growing heart-shaped herb will still
have been killed off by killmonger like they're
still dealing with that plot point and I think
sure he is trying to find a technological
workaround for the lack of heart-shaped herb
like she's trying to find a way to recreate
it with her technology and part of the other
characters thinking that she might be dead
during the movie has something to do with
that obviously she comes back though I think
all this footage of her fighting with the
Black Panther Panther suit on with her black
panther suit on is much later in the movie
we also get a bunch more footage of Riri Williams
ironheart in her Mark II suit this is the
second version of her suit that she creates
inside shuri's lab with the advanced technology
like the first suit she creates in the Cambridge
area like near MIT where she used to go to
school I think she gets kicked out during
the events of the movie but the first suit
she dumpster dive it looks a little bit more
cobbled together it looks a little bit like
this in the promo art it's a little bit clearer
look at it once they take her to wakanda and
start protecting her there she gets access
to shuri's technology in her lab that's when
she creates the more advanced Mark II version
of the suit and if it wasn't clear zoom and
enhance she's fighting Namor during these
scenes they also have a couple funny moments
in the trailer with the characters reacting
to namor's vibranium like oh he's got vibranium
all over him that's going to be a problem
and that on top of his mutant abilities which
probably give him some enhanced strength obviously
the ability to fly or what make him so strong
such a big threat like you see him destroying
all this stuff all over wakanda and just thrashing
all these people around like even M'Baku seems
like he's having trouble with him them that's
why imbaku is also telling his people during
their big war planning meeting here why namor's
people think of him as a living God mostly
because of the mutant Powers I'm really interested
to see how they weave in sort of the name
or comic book Canon the whole idea that in
the comics they call him the first mutant
because he's like the first comic book character
to debut but chronologically there might be
actual older mutants that we just haven't
learned about in the MCU before some of the
mutants some of the X-Men characters like
Wolverine for instance Hugh Jackman's character
are coming in Via Multiverse like during Deadpool
3 but in the next couple of years like as
we build up to like our next big X-Men movie
Inside the MCU we'll probably learn a little
bit more about which characters are coming
from the Multiverse and which mutant characters
have been here the whole time and we're just
learning about now if you're not a big black
panther or Comics reader one of the other
big things they've introduced in a lot of
this trailer footage are the midnight Angels
so this special blue armor that you see a
koye wearing you also see Michaela Cole wearing
she's playing a version of Anika from the
comics they're called the midnight Angels
they're like the special ops team within the
door milage so the whole idea is the dorm
Elijah are like the special forces of wakanda
they're already meant to be like their most
hardcore Warriors they come from all the different
tribes they're like six main tribes of wakanda
it'd be like trying to join the special forces
in the military like normal selection process
only the most badass Warriors get to join
but within the door milaje they have an even
more hardcore smaller group called The Midnight
angels that use way more advanced technology
they go on more spec ops missions and it seems
like in the trailer some of the dorm Elijah
and the midnight angels are fighting each
other like midnight Angels versus Dora milaje
that might have something to do with what
raimonda is doing in this whole war that they're
having with namor's people I think the idea
is that there are a lot of different ideas
within wakanda amongst Ramada surely the other
people about what they should do about what's
going on with Namor because it seems like
raimonda goes on the war path and that kind
of makes things worse and I think long term
the idea is that they don't want to kill Namor
off he's meant to be more of an anti-hero
inside the MCU the way they're playing him
he just wants to protect his people even even
though he does seem kind of like an if you've
ever read any name or Comics you kind of know
his relationship with black panther he's like
that in the comics too most the time when
people think about black panther versus namor
in the comics they just think about the different
fights that they have it's sort of like Hulk
and Wolverine like they have this ongoing
series of rematch fights across the years
just this low-level beef between each other
even though the MCU t'challa is dead they're
sort of carrying that forward and they did
say that what t'challa did at the end of the
first Black Panther movie sort of revealing
wakanda itself is existence to the rest of
the world the truth of wakanda will have something
to do with name Wars beef with wakanda so
even though you can't have Namor vs t'challa
because that would be really cool they're
using a lot of that comic book Vibe with the
name or story in the movie but also them using
the character so much in this movie is the
reason why you didn't see a version of Namor
on the Illuminati during the doctor strange
2 movie the writer of Doctor Strange 2 said
that was a big thing like oh namor was already
booked doing something else this was the something
else but because we only have a couple way
least before the movie comes out we'll get
a little bit more footage so I'll keep doing
bonus videos as we get closer if you have
any questions about the characters or what's
going on with the movie or how it's going
to influence the MCU just write it in the
comments below and I'll add to my future bonus
videos my Black Adam post credit scene video
will post later today and then my full Black
Adam breakdown and Easter eggs will post tomorrow
my house the dragon finale video will also
post this weekend too everyone click here
for my house of the Dragon episode 10 finale
video and everyone click here for my Black
Adam post credit scene video I'll update the
link as soon as I post that thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and I'll see
you guys in the next one!